what's up people we are back in
Roseanne's kitchen Kelly Carlin and I
hope you know me already David Rubin and
Kelly you you're gonna handle this the
heavy lifting here because I asked you
for some topics what can we what can we
talk about and and you said something
about seasons yeah I just there's
something about winter I mean I don't
know if it was about 15 years ago I was
like really really disgusted by the
Christmas season and the whole
commercialization of it and everything
and I wanted to bring more meaning to
this time of year for me and I I've
really created this practice around it
which I really love which is about
retreating like literal retreating which
is kind of crazy this time of year
because you're supposed to be in the
mall shopping yeah and you can do a
little bit of that but I really believe
because the way the seasons are and
nature nature we're part of nature we
are animals hello yeah we that we
actually and naturally want to be part
of the season in this season it's cold
out maybe not in Southern California
where we are but it's cold out
everywhere else chilly you're actually
yes drizzling outside Rangers link out
to something but there's something about
retreating from that active outdoor have
to do everything kind of a life and
coming back into connection with your
inner world and connecting to what's
meaningful for you and really one of the
best ways to do that is to shut the rest
of the world out so no social media for
the last two weeks I've already lordy of
the year and I know there's a lot of
parties to go to and stuff like that and
you're working and all that kind of
stuff but you know work really slows
down this time of year maybe people take
off and if you have a chance to just
maybe turn off the electronics TV
included turn off the social media turn
off the computer maybe tell your email
hey I'm going to be gone for a week or
ten days or whatever and and get
reconnected to what it's like to just be
still in with yourself because if you
look outside and look at nature that's
what nature is doing yeah you know
plants are no longer making leaves and
animals are slowing down and some of
them are actually sleeping at
hibernating and there's something
magical I mean I think that's what this
time of year is always meant to be i
mean i think that's like what the whole
kind of Christmas thing is is like what
is holy and sacred to you yeah it's not
necessarily a 46 inch television yeah
and that's actually interesting that you
so you're in a way you can sort of take
the religious part yes he's in lately
and make it about the planet or the
earth or yeah ironmen which in a lot of
ways for most people I think sounds a
lot more decent or something it's like
an easier way to connect maybe and bring
us together yeah yeah I think I think I
think people for all the
commercialization and all the shopping
that goes on out there I think people
really don't like the commercialization
of this holiday yeah they feel obligated
by it and so maybe this year instead of
buying things for people maybe you paint
them a little watercolor something or
write a haiku or or just take some
pictures off your phone and you know and
make a little album for them or
something I mean just connecting on a
different level and for me I find this
is my most creative time where I feel
like I know we did another segment on
resolutions yeah I find that this is
when I can source what do I really want
for the next year what do I really want
for myself and my life next year do I
want to be more connected to my body
more connected to a spiritual practice
do I want to go for some big creative
goal but if you can silence the noise
you'll be able to actually hear the tiny
voice inside of you yeah so it's making
me think so we were also talking about
technology before and we were basically
saying that it's a net good the way it's
connected to us all that but this so
this is our chance to really yes like
you don't get that many chances in the
year maybe the end of summer when people
are shutting down right before the
school year but this is really one of
those little opportunities despite the
fact that the doors are now open
endlessly and sadly even on I did go to
best buy on black friday i like I joked
a joke joke but I ended up having a
friend in town and he wanted to get me a
gift for like a little housewarming
thing so I actually did go be with rain
I went to bestbuy and to target it was a
yeah and I didn't even get oh I did get
something at area but anyway um but this
is a chance yes to do that and yeah the
world we all want to stop in the world
does shut down now and yeah they really
you know right before Christmas and next
week it's nice because Christmas is kind
of in the mid
all the week yeah Sophie so Friday this
Friday shut it down people saturday boom
shut down and he's in that the only way
that will ever get the power back yeah
people because everyone does we all do I
did segment on it we all do complain
about it we feel this endless rat racing
and yet really the it's up to us the
stores won't stay open yep if people
don't go people don't show to buy
something it's true yeah all right well
are you guys gonna shut down I'm gonna
do so you're gonna do two weeks you're
in two weeks yeah I mean I have a little
bit of promoter I have to do for some
things because I say yes but you can are
you gonna schedule those too I'm gonna
schedule those tweets and those things
so he there's always trickery i think is
now i really want out i do all right i
want to know what you guys are doing are
you shutting down for the holidays are
you can do a little more alone time a
little more family time a little time
away from all the electronic stuff
except for the Rubin report obviously
let us know right down below